good morning believe nation today's
message is fight for your beliefs over
to you Marco Pierre White many people
have condemned me for being
controversial
I was never controversial as I've always
said
most of my reputation is the product of
exaggeration and ignorance did I shout
yes I did but I led from the front I
nailed my colours to the mast I fought
for my profession if you're gonna be a
rebel make sure you win it'll be a
revolutionary then fight what you truly
believe in and that's all I ever did and
the boys behind me they followed me most
people don't know what they stand for
and so they don't know what they're
fighting for most people are lost and
that's why they end up following
somebody who has more certainty who has
more self-awareness than they do instead
of living their own life instead of
being a leader for yourself you're
following somebody else who just has
more confidence and self-awareness you
need to know what you stand for to know
what you're fighting for this is why I
wrote the book and not some promotional
piece here it's super important it's
identifying what is the one thing that
you will not compromise what is the one
most important core value to you
most people don't know and if you don't
know then how are you living a life and
running the business with any kind of
purpose
you'll just be constantly reacting to
what other people are giving you you're
living somebody else's life and not your
own and so I think the self-awareness is
one of the most important things that
you can have not just as an entrepreneur
but as a human being for you to know
what your one word is if you don't know
what your one single most important core
value is it becomes a lens through which
you see the world
now you can proactively build a business
and proactively create a life that
reflects your most important core vows
now you know what to fight for now you
know what you're no longer willing to
accept because you've always shown these
tendencies you've always gravitated
towards this one word this one core
value but it was always half Heather's
it was always when things come up is
always random and so what are the
chances that that perfect mentor or
guide a relationship or business
opportunity is going to just fall on
your lap it can happen but it's a small
percentage well now if you purposely are
setting out to build a business and a
life around your most important core
value that percentage is going to
dramatically explode now you're no
longer willing to be around people who
don't share the values that you do now
you're not going to be with people who
pound down your ideas who tell you all
the reasons why you're not going to be
successful now you're going to be open
to opportunities and they're gonna find
you that support you in doing great
things most people though haven't
figured it out most people won't figure
it out and it's why most people will not
be great leaders that's why most people
will never build a great life it's why
most people walk around feeling like
they could be doing so much more in
their life and they're not even coming
close to reaching their potential
doesn't mean you have to be down in the
dumps doesn't mean you have to had no
success as those people who have plenty
of success but they know that they could
be doing more they know they're nowhere
close to their ceiling and they don't
know how to get there and they don't
know what's wrong what's wrong is you
don't know what you staying for what's
wrong is you don't know what you're
fighting for what's wrong is you just
following other people and send via the
leader you are meant to be so find your
one word find your single most important
core value and then you found what you
should be fighting for so the question
that today is I'm curious what is your
one word what is the single most
important thing that you are fighting
for I want the one word and I want a
sentence or two as to why it really
means something to you why is it so
important to you leave in the comments
and we'll join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to David
David thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word
really really really appreciate the
support I hope you're enjoying it thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso hey believe nation thank you so
much for watching if you want to learn
more about this subject get a little bit
deeper on it I'm going to share some
extra bonus clips that I hope you'll
enjoy and what I'm telling artists is
you got to have balls it got to let
these guys know if you're a DJ be a DJ
if you're a radio personality be a radio
personality and nothing more we make the
music that allows them to have a voice
on a radio and they took control and try
to say say that they have all the power
and gonna dictate what we have to do I
spoke out against it so they got a dummy
to go up there and be a dummy on the
radio and speak on their behalf and talk
about me and it's really unfortunate
because he they using him and he's not
even a part of my fight my fight is a
big fight my fight is against any power
structure that's going to try to hold
back the freedom of speech and that
fight ain't over yet amazed at how few
people have a belief system what do they
actually believe in I and and yeah it's
okay to offend you guys 90% of you will
do what's expected of you as opposed to
what you want to do and you know I even
when I come to an event like they said
why am I here
why would I even bother to take an hour
of my valuable time no it's true
I have to have a purpose my goal is very
simple if I can convert one of you
there's probably 400 500 people here if
I can convert one of you to follow your
belief and have the guts to follow your
belief I'll have all think of the hour
as well spent but so I always say what
am I trying to do and why I don't speak
because somebody you know will write
nice things about it I always sort of
have a purpose but I have a belief
system
and most people even successful
companies and have big beef with fortune
500 CEOs I can talk about this very
little leadership there don't have an
internal compass of what they believe in
its what do others expect you know when
I graduated I went into entrepreneurship
nobody went into entrepreneurship out of
the business school and people said why
wouldn't you work for Goldman or
McKinsey I said why would you like I
couldn't fathom why you would want to do
that job
right I still can't by the way for those
of you going to those places and I'm
sure there's plenty I'm probably not the
right person to talk to you I frankly
don't even care to talk to you all of
you others I think there's something
wrong with anybody who fundamentally
wants to go work for one of the
consultants or the investment banks
today in this part that does they don't
understand how the world is going to
work in the future but my point again is
have a belief system follow that compass
and I'm overstating it a bit so there
may be some hope for those of you going
there but it's a lonely a little bit of
an exaggeration let me go back to this
issue of fortune 500 CEOs I've talked to
many over the years if a New York Times
writer writes an article they want to
change their strategy they want to
respond how silly is that that some
English major who's never had a business
job can determine the strategy of a
fortune 500 company why because they
care about what's written not what their
belief system is do you know what the
lon must could say to that writer go get
a real job all right what Jeff Bezos
would say that's leadership having a
belief system knowing what's driving you
to do what you do not your fitting
to do career enhancement or making it
look good to somebody else whether it's
your friends or to your boss or to
shareholders and frankly you look at all
the companies that are languishing in
the valley the older companies they
generally don't have a belief system
they're generally trying to meet some
quarterly target without saying here's
how we will be different and here's how
we'll do it
Apple did languish for 10-15 years and
then Steve Jobs came in with a point of
view and created the most valuable
company in the world he did irrational
things if you go back to January of 2007
January 1 everybody was saying nobody
wants a phone without a keyboard nobody
wants a phone that costs $6.99 I can go
on with the litany those were all
English majors writing articles I have
this beef against English majors not all
English majors are bad but the majority
of them at Stanford are undirected and
don't have a goal or a purpose sorry and
that's not to say among them there isn't
20% that are really good they just
didn't get the right guidance and ended
up in the wrong place
I like purposeful education